like a family you also feel like a bunch
of dumbasses just gonna blow my buzz
almost Christmas is the perfect family
comedy for the holidays but the cast
agreed Monique
sold the show Monique is a force of
nature and Jayde when you put JB and
Monique together it's like a combustible
fuel and I got to benefit because I had
all these amazing takes me and Monique
did two can play that game together so
many years ago and she's never lost to
me she's the queen of comedy for a
reason and she brought it full force in
this movie this is why a dream come true
for any actor what was it like working
with Monique someone like I can't wait
to get in a worker it again we talked
about her as a comedian but she's such a
wonderful actress you know all those
moments and all those rich moments that
we had together from the moment that she
steps on the screen that I have with her
to enter the last moment at the end of
the film it's just so wonderful I'm his
wife you dumb [ __ ] you dumb [ __ ] young
[ __ ] silly [ __ ] stay a bit she got the
gun [ __ ] memorable moment was probably
monique cussing everybody out in the
foyer
she said what rating is this baby and I
said Monique is whatever rating you or
she's just masterful and brilliant and
Gabrielle Union character we're trying
to give him you some love and basketball
vibes can you tell me what it was like
to work with her again but having her as
your love interest this time it was
great it was a lot of innocent fun and
trying to like port her and in those
ways
you know he's saying okay mama it felt
like some some ends while we didn't tie
some intimate relationships in the end
and that kind of made me feel like there
may be a sequel in the works can you
confirm that there is a sequel in the
works and there were and there were some
open-ended things for the sequel and so
yes yes we're working on a sequel right
now can't wait I am like finished a
script let's get started